I wanna be a billionaire so freakin bad
and maybe you do too
the idea becoming richer is so ingrained
in US culture that it's actually the
central theme of the American Dream the
idea of the American Dream is of course
that anyone from any background can get
to the top of American society but you
don't have to take his word for it
listen to these politicians try to sell
you on it
the condition of your birth does not
determine the outcome of your life in
this country we have never been a nation
of haves and have-nots we are a nation
of haves and soon to haves or look at
music and movies from literally any
decade
[Music]
hey fam I mean Mayan and this Sunday
we're explaining how to become a
billionaire your odds of becoming the
next Jeff Bezos and how you can acquire
so much wealth you'll never ever have to
worry about saving money by filling your
gas tank only halfway so you can drive
to work to film video all about becoming
a billionaire yay let's do this if
you're watching this video then you're
probably in the top 100 percent of all
income earners and you want to get into
an even more exclusive tier there was a
time when a million dollars was big
money like that time that was a show
dedicated to that premise okay you're
ready yes here we go let's play Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire
now a million bucks is just something a
billionaire feels like when he's sick
the sad truth is that from the
perspective of very rich people today a
million dollars is not a lot of money
that's venture capitalists and early
Amazon investor Nick Hanauer and he's
one of the more than 1500 billionaires
globally it's a very exclusive and
elusive Club that includes these names
cue money music the billionaire crew is
a group where right now there are eight
people who have as much money as 3.6
billion of the world's poorest people
Henner says that type of income
disparity is that for the wealthy and
the poor the challenge for business
owners of wealth inequality is that if
most people have no money then who will
buy the stuff sometimes it can be
difficult to visualize just how big the
financial discrepancy is trigger warning
I'm about to break down just how much
money you'd have to have to be a
billionaire the average income for the
top 1% is more than 1.1 million dollars
it's about five hundred and fifty four
dollars an hour for a typical work week
and that's just the 1% earnings
billionaires are the top point zero zero
zero zero one percent they're making way
more than that petit five hundred and
fifty four dollars an hour let me give
you some examples legendary investor
Warren Buffett made what average out to
be about twenty five thousand six
hundred ninety four dollars per minute
in 2013 if that was your hourly rate you
could retire a millionaire in just 40
minutes stag retirement goes huge
president Donald Trump's favorite
billionaire campaign call out in 2016
I have Carl Icahn already endorsed speak
well he made a lot less than Buffett
just fourteen thousand four hundred and
ninety two dollars a minute which makes
him wait for it still a billionaire
meanwhile the federal minimum wage is
$7.25 per hour it'll probably take less
than 25 years for the world to get its
first trillionaire and it'll likely be
either this guy or that
economist mark wise says that's a
problem of I'm a trillionaire I can buy
politics and we live in a democracy
thoughts of problem before you can get
to trillions you have to make a pit stop
at billions how easy is it for you to
meet Bezos in the billionaire baller
bracket while wiki house says it's as
simple as a three-part plan which
includes creating opportunities
investing in the business and
maintaining wealth what the article
seems to imply is that everyone working
on being in the three comma Club is
already in the two comma Club but most
people aren't and the real very first
step to being a billionaire is taking a
look at where you're starting according
to Richard Wilkinson who spent his
entire career studying wealth countries
a bigger income difference father's
income is much more important
determinant of how well children do so
the tendency for rich fathers to have
rich sons and poor fathers have poor
sons is much stronger in more equal
societies got it
classic life hat have wealthy parents
and certainly if you if you take a look
at the life paths of the wealthiest
people in our country not a one of them
started at the bottom from Bill Gates to
Jeff Bezos to Sergey Brin to Larry Page
you know these are people who came from
families with resources stability and
privilege there are so many ways it's
easier for wealthier people to make
money versus they're less rich
counterparts they have the benefits of
financial safety nets if investments
fail and they sometimes decide their own
salary think powerful CEOs the average
CEO makes 271 times what the average
worker earns the gap between CEOs at the
top and the average worker and the same
company has increased enormous Lee over
time and it looks as if CEOs incomes are
not related to company performance a
discussion about acquiring bass golden
diamond-encrusted mountains of wealth is
also a conversation about income
inequality
and a good display of how this wealth
gap has developed starts in the
post-world War two ERA and the return of
a happier day earnings grew fast and at
the same rate on all runs of the income
ladder if you adjust for inflation the
money doubled the gap between people
higher and lower on the income ladder
was still substantial but the disparity
didn't actually change much during those
decades then the economic slowdown of
the 1970s happened a long line because
the recession here has caused a 10
percent jump each month in the number of
those needing help those at the top
continue to see their dollars grow but
the middle and lower-income households
saw their gains dropped sharply the
disparity between the groups got bigger
which means you'll need to have stronger
thighs to jump across that wage gap
there's basically being a slowdown to a
complete halt in terms of mobility
between classes in the United States
it's as if the social ladder was much
steeper or the rungs on the ladder
further apart check out this chart it
shows just how much and how quickly in
the last 40 years the divide between the
haves and marco rubio's so-called soon
to haves has ballooned the data
basically says the easiest and most
recommended way to become a billionaire
is to be a multi-millionaire the
American Dream is based upon the idea
that everyone and anyone in the US has
an equal opportunity to gain success and
prosperity it's code for you too can be
rich but for regular people how much do
the stats supports the implication of
the American dream how realistic is the
American dream Wow well most dreams are
not very realistic other the u.s. is
behind countries like Denmark Norway
Finland and Spain when it comes to
social mobility our northern neighbor
Canada is better at seeing people rise
in wealth and class even the developing
nation of Pakistan is beating us in this
department
the US has many obstacles that
disproportionately keep the poor from
gaining wealth
there are payday lenders targeting the
less financially flexible and charging
them interest rates as high as nineteen
hundred percent credit card companies
willing applicants who aren't fiscally
stable enough to pay on time and then
charging them higher interest rates and
banks charging late fees and overdraft
fees that can bleed already anemic
counts it is extraordinarily expensive
to be poor it is it is expensive and
difficult for instance not to own your
own car it's expensive to need to live
far from your job because housing prices
near your job are prohibitively
expensive the poor often regard
themselves as poor because they didn't
have what it took people don't
understand the wider social
environmental impact of inequality and
social status now impoverished people
are twenty times less likely than they
weren't in 2001 to believe that hard
work will get them ahead and only 38
percent of Americans believe their
children will have a better life than
they've had there are so many other
statistics we could include like how
race and gender affect people's average
income earnings and chances of moving up
that literally could be an entirely
separate video and luckily we've already
made those videos and have link to them
below and by the way we tried to get
commented for this story from literally
all of the minority women billionaires
in America but we couldn't get a hold of
Oprah but one thing you should know is
that your quest to become a billionaire
may be affected by your political
leanings 66% of Republicans and those
who lien rights say hard work instead of
a person's advantages have more to do
with why they're rich Democrats and
those that lean left feel the exact
opposite 60% say a person is rich
because they've had more advantages than
others as opposed to just working hard
there are a bunch of extraordinarily
hard-working people in our society that
that are desperately poor and kept that
way for structural reasons and there are
a ton of people in our society who are
enormous ly rich who are lazy
good-for-nothing clowns and got rich
because they were in the way of some
type you know tidal wave of money or
they inherited or got lucky the truth is
that making the move to billionaire
status isn't easy unless you or your
family are already multimillionaires and
if you're not in the upper class what
you'll need to make it to the next stage
of wealth is much more than those above
you
we spent so much time in this video
talking about how to become a
billionaire but the real question may be
if you should become one bigger income
differences damages the health of the
whole population
you also see much higher rates of
violence I think that it's a very
unethical to have these enormous
inflated salaries at the top it in the
context of our current economy today
having people who are worth that much
money is almost certainly a failure of
policy and morality hey fam don't forget
to like share and subscribe let us know
in the comments section how many of you
are billionaires and come back next week
even if you're not one bye